this is a production of Cornell
University why don't to thank all the
graduate students as well it's been fun
for me so far I think I was placed
appropriately an order of speakers I
learned a lot just listening before my
presentation so today I want to talk to
you a little bit about the lay Institute
where I work
I said Institute that's founded about 40
years ago with with a certain set of
uncommon problems or uncommon goals in
mind and I'd like to begin with a quote
from the founder of the Institute West
Jackson and West says that it's
impossible for us to operate in our
daily lives and not create the world
that everyone must live in what we
desire arranges the genetic code in all
of our major crops and livestock we
cannot avoid participating in the
creation and it is in agriculture far
and away our largest and most basic
artifact that human culture and the
creation totally interpenetrate and this
is very real very obvious as we look at
how humans have changed the landscape of
the world today if we look you know in
the mountains of China where we have
paddy rice systems in terraces or Greg
County Kansas the Candice Nebraska
irrigated agriculture areas or places
like I was in January ty Bay Palestine
where through agriculture over thousands
of years we've eroded away the soil that
was there to a point where not only can
we not do agriculture in here anymore
but the ecosystems that preceded them
the oak savannas that were there before
cannot reestablishing that for hundreds
of years
and so what we've done through
domestication in the technologies that
we've developed to create the
agriculture that we have today is fairly
amazing and if we look at a map of the
amount of human appropriation of net
primary productivity around the world we
see that many of the areas we think of
as being very productive
we're appropriating up between 60 and 80
percent of the biomass the net primary
productivity that would have been there
before agriculture so we're in the 80%
range of the ecosystems that we were
replacing with and that's that's pretty
amazing when we think about what the
crops that we've domesticated started as
but the way that we're growing those
cups crops has problems so if we think
about how our crops are grown they're
grown in these systems that require
continual disturbance they're kept at a
ecosystem level that's early in the
successional gradient right so we never
allow ourselves to develop these systems
to retain nutrients and as a result we
have leaky agro ecosystems and so we see
that in our cropping systems we have
losses of biodiversity from those
landscapes in those systems we have
losses of soil resources from those
systems and we continue to lose
nutrients through volatilization through
leaching through runoff and etc and this
is ultimately an inefficient try this is
keeping our net priority down and to
maintain the net primary productivity
those systems we have to supplement
those ecosystems with continuous inputs
so just a like look at biodiversity loss
this is a this is a map of the United
States showing the counties in the US
every county that has a color at least
20% of the cropland in that county is
devoted to crop production
and you know we look around it big
portions of the US we have a small
effective crop number meaning you know
on 20% of the landscape just maybe only
three four maybe only one or two species
that are making up you know that are
thinking of the surface area of their
landscape I'm from Nebraska and my
family farms and York County Nebraska
and this is very interesting mean
somehow there's like three to four
effective crop species on the landscape
but out of the three hundred sixty-six
thousand acres that are there 84% of
them were voted to crop production and
you know eighty to eighty two and a half
percent are devoted to just two crops
corn and soybean production and we think
about okay what's happening on those
other 16 percent of the acres well you
know there's a couple of towns there's a
lot of roads we have a golf course
there's a few parks and that's that's
about it and I think it's really easy
for us to be desensitized to those
environments that's normal for me and I
was talking with some of the other
speakers I flew into Detroit on my
commute here you know I always look out
the window and I see an ad here and I
see a quarter section here and it's
normally you know perfect grid square
line and it was really interesting
flying into Michigan where you still see
the sections but there was like the back
40 or a 20 that was devoted to timber
still um it was something that was a
part of that culture I guess that was
there before that's not a part of mine I
haven't seen something like that and
where I'm from you
the thing that is is really important to
remember is that we're losing a lot of
soil from our our agro ecosystems we
look at a natural ecosystem there is
soil formation right we have better
Genesis we're building soil through rock
weathering really really slow you know a
thousandth of a millimeter per year for
developing new technologies and new
techniques to do agriculture better and
one of those is no-till agriculture
or still having net losses of soil on an
annual basis and a small percentage of
our agriculture is devoted to no-till we
have about 5% notes so in the u.s. right
now the majority that our culture is
still plowed we're losing up just up to
you know one and a half millimeters of
soil per year from those landscapes and
if we think about now what does
sustainability mean you don't have soil
left to do agriculture where's that
where is that food going to come from so
you know we can look at soil losses
around the world in 2012
most of our most productive areas are
still losing you know enormous amounts
of soil look at you know here's the Iowa
Illinois region we're losing five to ten
five to ten metric tons per hectare of
soil think about you know the volume of
soil that that is and where is it going
right the other thing that we've lost
from most of the soils is the organic
matter that was there we lost lose it a
co2 through respiration and oxidation of
the soil organic content and so this is
a map I farmed a little bit my
cousin-in-law in Kansas now and this is
a map of one of our fields and you can
see here really clearly so my
cousin-in-law took the field over about
eight years ago all the stuff that's
yellow and green this was native
pastures it hadn't been tilled in anyone
that could remember his lifetime so we
have strong organic levels that are in
the you know threes fours fives and even
sixes there's areas that are red those
have been farmed continuously for the
last you know unknown number of decades
and this is pretty typical I mean look
at our in the world just 30 40 years of
tillage we reduced the soil organic
matter that was there by you know 30
percent that's a 50 or 60 percent
depending where we are at so organic
matter is very important right that's
our nutrient storage system is how we
store the water that our crops need
that's how we store the nitrogen that
our crops mean that's where the
phosphorus is that's where everything is
and when we lose them when we have sand
it's even more important for us to
continue adding inputs to the system
every year to maintain the fertility and
the productivity of those systems not to
mention the co2 that we're losing right
some of that co2 that's in the organic
matter is old prime that primary from
how many years ago we were unsure and so
um the other thing that we lose often is
our nitrogen and our phosphorus losses
so most of our phosphorus losses right
that's imported phosphorus that's an
omen or that's rock phosphate that's
mine
from around the world and nitrogen is
the same way we know that this has major
consequences and you know these aren't
just some unique outcome of Agriculture
these are predictable consequences of an
agriculture practice in the way that
we're doing in my keeping or a Greek
assistance at this early stage secondary
succession so now we have hypoxic areas
around the world dead zones around the
world we have you know the largest dead
zone in the world this year 20,000
hectares annually in size and we're not
doing that much to address this issue
we're projected that we're going to
continue increasing our nitrogen inputs
annually you know we 2% of the world's
energy every year goes to creating
synthetic nitrogen it's a huge reason
why we're all here is because of that
unique invention but we're we have not
really improved our nitrogen use
efficiency very much in the u.s. now
we're in the 60% range but globally our
global average is about 42 percent
nitrogen use efficiency so 1% of the
world's energy is creating nitrogen
that's not used it's running off and
leaving the system house whereas I just
oxide emissions a potent greenhouse gas
or as nitrate leaching into groundwater
supplies or runoff into into our
bring ecosystems so really you know as a
consequence of agriculture and human
activity in general we're beginning to
cross these planetary bound but
boundaries humans are now you know the
the biggest determining factor of
climate and environmental effects and
that's a unique time in history you know
that one species is controlling so many
things and so if we look at what kind of
boundaries we've already crossed you
know we've already crossed about four we
know that our climate is increasing at a
rate that we have uncertainty about what
the risks of that are going to be some
things like genetic diversity loss and
land system change from a forest
ecosystem that's holding the carbon in
place and the nutrients in place to our
cropping system they've also crossed
these boundaries and what's very
interesting to me you know we have
really disrupted these biogeochemical
flows through our nitrogen and
phosphorus fertilizer inputs and you
know we have UN agencies and
international agreements about things
like climate change and what
temperature's you want to talk be it but
we haven't really addressed this issue
you don't have an international agency
or agreed-upon
you know levels of inputs we're just
continue to project with we haven't
really used nitrogen on the whole
African continent and that's a place
where we imagine right now they're in
the 80s for nitrogen use efficiency but
as soon as they begin really applying it
we imagine that efficiency is going to
go way down and so you know when we talk
about you know uncommon uncommon common
plants for uncommon goals so uncommon
goals of plant breeding a barb plant
science of our research you know these
are still pretty uncommon goals in or at
a time in history where they need to
become our common goals all of us need
to be thinking about things as a
graduate student but where is your crop
bone what soil type is it growing on
what's the vulnerability of that soil
what do we have to do to maintain the
fertility of those soils I think it's
very important for us to consider in the
future and you know more importantly how
are we going to address these issues
what can we
changing our crops and so the land
institute West Jackson once again you
know this is what he says
so since nature as the most sustainable
ecosystem and since ultimately
agriculture comes out of nature our
standard for a sustainable world to
denature zone ecosystem so let's look at
some ecosystems that have reached this
later term secondary succession where we
have proper earth systems we have the
nitrogen cycle that's functioning we're
retaining your traditional system and
what do we notice about those you know
whether it's the Prairie whether it's a
tropical rainforest or savanna or even
coastal wetlands and Tyga's and Tundras
all of these ecosystems are composed of
you know really noticeable things one
they all are predominantly made of part
of perennial crop perennial species
perennial plant species and - it's never
just a single species there's some
species might be more dominant in the
goose ISM and others but there's always
diversity in those systems so this is
becoming the goal of our organization
when we look at a natural ecosystem
right because we're pretty long height
and high diversity we have soil
formation happening we have increased
soil organic matter we're retaining
nutrients in the system we have a
habitat that allows for a functional
soft soil microbiome to develop and we
actually have water infiltration we
don't have Rock like in Palestine where
the water just lands on the rock and
runs on the hill we're using the
nutrients they're landing on that
constitute and we will look at our
entire ecosystems you know they're
characterized by annuals crops low
diversity we have soil erosion we have
reductions in soil organic matter we
have nutrient losses we don't have
functioning slow microbiomes we have
poor water infiltration and in a lot of
landscapes so we're trying to envision a
new we call natural systems agriculture
that's not natural it's still engineered
it's still humans we are still the ones
that are affecting the climate in the
environment right by designing these
systems
they're composed of perennial crop
species they have moderate diversity and
you know that we envision them as
actually allowing soil formation to
happen having increased soil organic
matter retaining nutrients having
functional soil microbiome and
infiltrating water that's landing
and so you know what are some of the
reasons that maybe these later
successional turn successional
ecosystems are functioning and you know
on we can see that we actually probably
have increase in that primary
productivity this is a field in Kansas
this is a field that's been filed it's
about to be planted to sunflowers at the
same time of the year this is one of our
researchers feel to institute this is
Silphium which is a perennial relative
of sunflower and the Asteraceae family
and you can see it's big and growing and
so when we have living root systems
they're gonna begin growing doing
photosynthesis as soon as the
environmental conditions are appropriate
produced to do so as soon as we have
warm enough temperatures in the spring
they're gonna be actively growing and
hopefully someday as a whole you know we
can see that instead of taking away most
of the net primary productivity has seen
from the system we have a larger pool of
net primary productivity begin from and
we can still take large yields of seed
away leaving some of the net primary
productivity there to feed the soils and
to build the organic matter and those
other ecosystems that we need for a
bunch of slow microbiomes
so we also can see that primality can
increase the soil organic carbon and we
look at temperate grasslands perennial
species out there and in general
perennials have a forty to sixty percent
below ground allocation of their net
primary productivity and so a lot of the
organic material that's landing in the
landscape is actually going into living
ranks in the soil in our annual grains
we only have fifteen to twenty percent
below ground allocation of net primary
activity it's turning over each year so
though this is the vision of the lands
like this this is an uncommon goal but
one that we know is possible this at the
top is intermediate wheat grass species
that we've been domesticating with other
people around the world for a quite a
few years and on the bottom is our
annual wheat and you can see the
differences in the net primary
productivity the system and the amount
of organic matter of carbon that's
entering the soil each year in those
root systems
so this is really the vision of the
future you know you guys can stay in
this and in addition to bringing carving
into the systems these large living root
systems
you know accomplished most well their
goals when grown on slopes they can
limit water erosion we're covering the
soil and holding the soil all year every
year and we can also you know limit our
water contamination so the water that's
there is being infiltrated we have large
living root systems that are gonna be up
taking all of the nitrate that's that's
in our soil and preventing runoff into
our streams so instead of planting you
know a buffer strips in and around our
fields we have field scale buffer strips
and it's something that I hope that we
can envision in dream resource
partitioning in diverse systems so when
we look at a diverse system we have you
know biomass and we have root organs and
plant organs of all different shapes and
sizes and some of them are big tap root
steeping reaching deep in the soil and
we have no fibrous root systems that are
putting a lot of matter into the top of
the soil and we really have this
partitioning this niche partitioning
that happens in a secondary later term
successional ecosystem so we're
capturing nutrients and holding them in
place at all levels of the soil profile
we're capturing sunlight in water at all
levels in the system and so you know we
can imagine even with perennial grains
right if we have a perennial servitor
right species we have some ecosystem
services that we're accomplishing we're
holding the soil in place we're
providing continuous living roots there
that are creating habitat for things
possibly like amf fungi and other soil
microorganisms as we add new species
like alfalfa to this mixture we have
another additional ecosystem service
that we can provide we have these
nodules providing habitat for nitrogen
fixing fixing rhizobia species and
ultimately we're bringing nitrogen into
the into the system to facilitate the
growth and development
our solid organic nitrogen pool and
other plants and organisms in the system
and finally you can imagine that we had
a maybe a thirsty she's a perennial
sunflower type of relative that in
addition to growing additional biomass
and and using the resources there is
also providing you know habitat for
beneficial insects for pest control and
habitat for other wildlife and our
systems and ultimately you know we have
this gradient of soil health that is
improved through this process and so
these are really the uncommon goals of
our institute we're working to develop
perennial grain crops three
domestication so this species
intermediate grass here is a pretty
allot relative of wheat and we have a
direct domestication program for them
probably or through wide hybridization
so we have multiple other programs we're
looking at other combination with grain
crops that we're trying to eat
harmonization to bring ferny allottee
into those species and finally in
addition we're trying to deploy these
grains in diverse crop assemblies on
agricultural landscapes and so in
addition to the lannister we have
collaborators all around the world that
are interested in working on these same
crops and cropping systems with us it's
really increasing quickly we have a
pretty low rice reading program and
researchers that we're working on that
have developed you know rice for days
that are planted on thousands of
hectares already and have been almost
equally as productive as the annual rice
or variety is growing in those same
regions six harvests in a row three
three three years to tumour tune events
and so for any elude the game breeding
that's what i do the land institute
hired me in 2016 legume breeder was the
international year of the pulses FAO is
here and the year before was the
International Year of the soils and so
we recognized the importance of pulses
and legumes in this idea of what a
sustainable future agriculture could
look like
very interesting I really enjoyed
Allison's talk today and I think you
know looking into the future the one
thing that we're missing still is is the
nitrogen cycle we need sustainable
inputs of nitrogen into our system and
the games are one way that we can do
that especially a perennial you get the
you accomplished you know that's
developing a long term root system and
you're slowly releasing nitrogen into
the soil that's becoming part of the
soil organic nitrogen pool we also know
for example like well we'll just keep
sucking here so I was hired in 2016
without a species or a crop or even a
vision of exactly how the pretty all the
games were gonna fit into the system and
so that was interesting and so I started
at late fall 2016 and I remember kind of
sitting in my office with a set of
questions that are still the same
questions that I'm asking today and you
know so like the first question is what
what legumes are perennials which
legumes are there and what I can work
with a next question was which species
should I choose
you know how many are there and which
one can I work on you know the next
question
Larry's presentation was really nice you
know how do we develop an idiot type for
whatever species were working on and you
know eventually as a breeder how do I
develop a breeding program for that crop
so which legumes are perennial I
actually began working in a
collaborative project while I was still
at the University of Wisconsin as a
graduate student a couple of months
before I started the position with dr.
Alison Millers through this perennial
agriculture project global inventory and
so we wanted to build an inventory of
all the legume species and look at their
life histories so there was no you know
nice list of what are the what are the
pronoun the taxa in the fabaceae family
and which ones are annuals and which
ones are perennials and what type of
perennial they are and so we had this
idea that we want to have perennial
herbaceous legumes they fit into our
sort of envisioned cropping system of
things that are growing back every year
so out of twenty thousand some species
about 30 percent or printing alerts the
kind that were interested in forty eight
hundred and so you know now I had my
list of which ones are perennials but we
still have to decide which species are
choose there's a large number and what's
really interesting to me so there's you
know twenty thousand some species in the
fabaceae family as humans we use maybe
fifteen as foods that we eat and maybe
another 30 to 40 as a ones that we use
as forage crops and so there's this
whole broad amount of diversity that in
some instances where we're at risk of
losing and that we don't really know
that much about did we choose those 15
because those were the obvious
candidates the people know ten thousand
years ago when they started
domesticating plants around the world or
to just kind of happen was they're just
you know that one unique person who saw
that plant and was used to eating that
plant and thought oh I'm gonna try
planting the seeds one time and then it
and then it you know just kind of went
from there and so now is that this way
species should we choose and so the
night that was the next question I
focused on kind of my first few months
at the land Institute and really
developing this idea of you know what do
we want in a crop and so you know some
basic concepts we care about its
economic potential is it can we
establish it does what are the field
management strategies that I need is it
harvestable what's the yield potential
is it adaptable it can it be only grown
in a specific you know location in the
world or can it be grown all over the
place what are some of the seed quality
attributes
what's its nutritional profile does it
have any anti nutritional compounds and
it's can it be used like CBD and some
high-value product seems like a quick
way to commercialize a new a new species
and then you know very importantly what
are the ecosystem services that this
species could provide how does it
require resources how does it retain
resources does it provide other
provisions for other purposes is it dual
use can it be used as a fiber and a seed
crop and finally I was wanting to think
about the ease of breeding so we know
that things like claudi level and genome
size are really gonna be an important
criteria long term and how successful
we're gonna be and also this
availability of genetic resources and so
you know when you're a new scientist and
you want to start doing something your
first year availability of germ plasm
and genetic resources and then really
thinking about what's the what's the
quickest way that I can release
something that's useful in agriculture
dual-use became kind of the most
important criterias for me right now
we're still evaluating many other native
and wild species that haven't been used
before but moving forward with these
ideas and so when we think about what
perennial legume species are being used
right now well we have many common
peroneal forages especially alfalfa
alfalfa is probably the perennial
herbaceous species that's had the most
genetic research economic research and
we grow it everywhere so we've really
been looking hard at these pretty Oh for
there's people that I can collaborate
that know something about these crops
their seed available for me it really
makes sense to start with those species
and so we're looking at them as kaneo
companion looking
something that we can inter plant
between rows of other annual or
perennial grain species as as our
nitrogen input source and then also as
kind of the perennial grain for Neopost
idea can we harvest something that's
edible that can be used as a new pole
scrub and so that was sort of the
beginning of my how do we develop an
idio type and my first year I just kind
of ran with it right well probably you
want big seed so alfalfa is a great
example of a crop with really good
potential we have a whole seed industry
that's already existing to produce seed
for farmers we grow a lot of it in the
western United States in there sometimes
achieving yields you know six hundred
eight hundred thousand pounds on acre
without really breeding for those
characteristics and those are pretty
comparable to the lentil yields that are
in the same environment growing in very
similar ways and so you know I think at
first naive they're thinking well we
need to have bigger seeds for sure
because people aren't gonna want to eat
really small lentils and also you know
thinking about long term seed
establishment of forage legumes is
pretty hard we have to either kill a lot
and have really firm seed beds and plant
very shallowly which is the same as with
hemp it's a big challenge and so we
didn't want tillage to be part of our
long term cropping system and we also
can't have that much residue on the
solid surface of the soil because the
seeds are small I can't push up through
them and so I was hoping that you know
increasing seed size will help with
establishment as well and so we did a
little bit of work I started with this
germ plasm called al boria dr. Edwin
Bingham had worked on at the University
of Wisconsin for a long time and it's an
alfalfa wide Harvard with medicago
arborio which is a woody perennial shrub
from the Mediterranean it has seed size
that are quite a bit larger than
conventional alfalfa
and so one cycle of selection we saw
some interesting things you know out of
my half sibs I had families that were
really outperforming the alfalfa checks
in the experiment and as you know this
is just data from the USDA grain system
but if we look at the two subspecies of
medicago sativa compared to all of my
breeding populations as a whole now we
are actually shifting the seed size of
alfalfa in some way closer towards this
other species natural seed size another
crop that I'm really interested in is
same flowing it's another perennial
forage like you met has a long history
it's pretty fascinating in that we look
at archaeological evidence humans were
eating this at one point in time so
there's caves in Turkey and around that
area where we're finding charred remains
of these seeds now and there's been some
recent interest in actually using it as
a seed crop a grain crop already so
there's been a few studies in Italy and
in Europe where organic protein sources
are really in need and really expensive
and so they've been actually looking at
these seeds as a possible protein
delivery system and in feeding trials
with pigs and chickens and other mono
graphics like mice in general we haven't
seen any negative consequences there's
been good rates of gain that are
comparable to soybean meal and it seems
like there's a lot of promise it also
has you know when we think about idiot I
think lupins kind of encapsulate what I
imagine the morphology of a new
perennial grain would look like they
have this beautiful terminal regime that
has all these nice little flowers on it
you can imagine being skimmed off easily
with a combine and we expect this to be
one of the big problems with
domesticating perennial forbs in general
if there's a they don't really have this
nice determinate growth pattern and then
senescence pattern that we can think of
in our annuals dry down sort of
naturally on their own and are easily
harvest with the combine so you know
maybe in a system like this where we
have dry seed pods up above we can use a
stripper header on the combine and come
through and just skim them off the top
and if you've never seen a Lupin pottery
and they're super interesting to look
pretty much like a soybean pot so they
look like a stem of soybeans
with pods all the way up three or four
seeds in a pod and pretty good size we
have three other species of lupins that
have already been domesticated annuals
that are grown in the world actually one
of the species that was domesticated by
the Incas in South America its
progenitor is actually a perennial
species and so there's a lot of
opportunities to explore that in more
detail we can cross it with the native
species Lupin is prolly Phyllis that I'm
interested in so this is the ornamental
Lupin that you see planted in people's
flowerbeds there's been reading already
for these you know increased
reproductive output so it's an
interesting one for me and so you know I
started this second round of ok how do
we develop an idiot type and this is
really began when I started thinking
about companion legumes and how do you
breed for something that you're gonna
plant between rows of something else if
your phenotype is actually you know the
expression of a phenotype in a different
crop what is your how do you select for
that interaction and what what sort of
breeding system do you use and so we
have people have been trying this for
quite a lot one of the species I'm
working on is cure clover and we tried
using it as kind of this living
continuous cover mulch system especially
in Wisconsin can Albrecht worked on it a
lot in Wisconsin craig Schafer's worked
on it in the University of Minnesota and
we've tried all sorts of ways of trying
to kind of manage the compatibility in
the competition in that system but no
one has taken a breeding approach so no
one has really gone through is there a
way that we can select to change these
systems and so you know I began to think
about really didn't details so what is
our cropping system what's the row
spacing going to be what are we planting
it in between what are the limitations
of a candidate species in that system so
a lot of these new species that we try
you know I'm getting wild seed scent
from either our biome from native sieve
nurseries or there's like these wild
seed collection networks where they just
you email this person and they mail you
some seed back I collected this at this
place and so we have terrible
germination rates usually there's a lot
of out reading depression in genetic
load that's there and it's hard to
evaluate these things in plots even
because you know there's a they're hard
to compare
traits our components of seed yield so
even like in loopiness poly Felicity old
study we don't really know should I be
selecting for more seeds per pod or
should I be selecting for more flowers
on a Racine and which traits are
increasing the compatibility of my
legume in my mixtures and and finally
you know for these mixtures can I breed
plants in monoculture stands or in space
plant nurseries or do I have to do my
breeding in between rows of the
companion that they're going to be grown
with so one of the projects we started
last last year's last year was our first
year of phenotyping with technician and
master student in my lab it's really
trying to design these intermediate
wheat grass alfalfa by cultures so we
began a multi-state study we have about
30 varieties of alfalfa planted in
between rows of intermediate wheat grass
in Wisconsin Kansas and Minnesota really
trying to see you know these varieties
are really divergent entries are really
divergent we have branching root systems
tap root systems really quick regrowth
etc are there certain traits that are
correlated with the system in maybe are
there certain varieties that we can
already recommend to farmers to adopt
the system because Kern's a and we do
eat grasses in this early stage of free
commercialization and farmers are
beginning to plant it would be great if
we could you know have farmers start
planting this in a cropping system in a
way that we you know know a long term is
where we should be moving
and so we started designing a cropping
system and this is how we're running it
at the at the moment so both of them are
perennials they both produce a lot of
biomass and in late April early May
depending where you're at the alfalfa
almost begins to flower the first time
depending where you're at and the
intermediate wheatgrass has grown as
well and so you can actually have a
grazing event or a forage harvest here
just before this onset of chiller
elongation in last year our trials in
Kansas we were producing one and a half
or so tons of really high-quality dry
matter at that time after this forage
harvest we left to let it go and the
alfalfa is gonna start flowering again
and in late May early June but because
it's between rows we can't really
harvest it and at this time the intimate
wheatgrass really starts closing up the
canopy and so when we look at the
alfalfa we're actually declining in
biomass continually from about this you
know May June transition until we
ultimately have mature seed that we're
harvesting from the intermediate grass
here at the end we have residue that we
can once again graze or or Bale and so
at this cutting last year averaging
about four and a half tons dry matter in
our plots that's not nearly as good
quality of hay but it would be fine as
grinding forage for heifer diets or beef
diets after that is first regrowing
again
and so by the middle of September we can
take a third cutting a third harvest or
a third grazing event where we're gonna
produce another 1/2 tons and so our
grain harvests are respectable last year
we were in the 700 or so pounds of seed
yield per acre but we also are producing
between 6 and 7 tons of dry matter and
so it's really this giulio system that
we can imagine farmers adopting
hopefully very quickly especially in
Kansas where we still have a tradition
of having these warm season pastures
that farmers are most farmers still own
a small herd of cattle and so you know
we're we're generally buying feed and
hay and feeding hay in this period of
time and so you know stretching
stretching it out and reducing the hey
we need to buy this time before we move
to our warm season pastures in the
middle of May would be a great benefit
and then once again once our warm season
pastures start declining in productivity
we can move them back to our cool season
grass legume mixture here and depending
how many feels we have you know we can
bulk residue and and graze throughout
the winter so it really fits nicely into
our system we're also looking at cura
clover and so Abbey Han is is here with
me she's a research resident Delana
student and we're really starting to
begin to understand you know what what
is controlling compatibility in this
system especially with maize and with
intermediate wheatgrass so we have a
project we've planted out all the
accessions in the USDA we're
characterizing really well using some
interesting morphometric proaches for
leaf size and area and shape and color
we looked at white clover research when
they're using in mixtures with grasses
the leaf color and the leaf shape and
size and really makes a difference in
the competitiveness of the curé clover
and in candace we really noticed this so
there's these clovers that have sort of
a bluish color and that's they're really
a waxing waxy coating on the leaves
that's really preventing water losses in
the system and those ones seem to
perform really well in our area so
finally how do we develop a breeding
program and so this has been a very fun
experiment for me to start from nothing
and so you know the first year we're
asking questions like know what pieces
of equipment do we have that we can
plant these things or how do I get the
seeds out of the pods of my alfalfa
plants how do I harvest my Lupin seeds
before they all shatter and fall on the
ground so I can measure yields or should
I not let them try not measure yield
should I just measure after everything
shattered is a way to find ones that are
into sin to isint and then also you know
because we don't have an idio type how
do we do breeding on the fly right how
are we going to develop an idiot i p--
and advanced populations we don't know
what to select for while we're still
doing the agronomic work to figure out
what the cropping system is and how it
should function and so this has been an
interesting experience for me and when
you think about a typical forage legumes
system pretty well we want to look at
yields for two three four years in a row
before we really make our selections so
we want this long-term yield stability
and so this is what I've started doing
this is just accurate clover example
we're really starting to do this with
the five species that I minced in
alfalfa pure clover Lupin's
same fine and alfalfa again as a grain
so we're starting with maybe a hundred
selected plants here in making a poly
cross in the greenhouse in the late fall
we did this last November and was we're
moving into you know the beginning of
year two or you know it's kind of year
one but we harvest the seeds from those
Hollett those poly crosses and maybe I
want to plant 100 100 seed so I have
10,000 total progeny that I'm gonna
evaluate that's a lot of plants to
evaluate and so we're gonna do some
selection here we're going to select
bigger seedlings that haven't succumbed
to diseases in the greenhouse
specifically inoculating them for traits
like the funnel my sees to resistance
which is a seedling disease in our area
in the spring we're just started doing
this Abby's been potting plants in the
greenhouse so we're gonna try to plot
the pot as many of these ceilings as we
can store about 2500 we're going to go
through another poly cross here to
produce new half sip seed families
basically or grants and families and we
want to be able to plant swords in the
field so this is typical kind of forage
research we want to go to source so that
we can evaluate on a whole plot basis we
don't expect that many of them to
actually produce enough seed to to plant
in Swords so we further reduce our our
our entry number by selecting the top
CEOs here and eventually we're gonna
plant them in plots in the field
intercropped with a species intermediate
grass after there or maybe in
monocultures for the grains
at the beginning of our second year this
would be the fall of of 2019 this fall
and hopefully we have enough plants that
actually produce seed to make two plots
that we can use some sort of partially
replicated design instead of having to
use Czech varieties and as we move into
our beginning of our third year here
we're starting to in the spring have our
first spring grazing simulation like I
showed you in that that first our
cropping system design we're gonna have
a summer grazing harvest and another
fall grazing here and we'll go through
that iteration three times these plants
are planted in monocultures space plants
and we're going to really evaluate you
know things like leaf area regrowth rate
fall dormancy and a variety of
characteristics that we can also use and
at the end of it we can select our top
1% of our plants at the same time we're
learning about our system we're learning
you know is this viable are there
certain traits that are better adapted
to this system yeah and in really
developing our ideo type through this
process hopefully starting in 2022
I guess fall 2021 we'll take those
hundred plants that we selected begin
moving towards a genomic selection
procedure we'll start the same way with
the hundred seeds harvest the seeds and
plant those 10,000 seedlings out but
ultimately begin selecting 100 progeny
each year based on the genomic
prediction model that we had developed
previously so we're designing an idiot
i'p we're learning about the plants
we're phenotyping all these things at
the same time as we go and splitting off
into you know additional cycles so
instead of having a five year cycle I'm
now on a one-year cycle but I'll take a
portion of these plants that will become
my next training population it's over
time basically have about 500 plots at
my one year age group my two year age
group and a three year age group of
plants in the field that were
continually cycling through and we
pick a species yet remember we have five
species so at the same time we're trying
to select species and so this is really
a way to compare effectiveness in a
cropping system you know a building in
the future - maybe perform as a grain
crop all simultaneously and a be
starting to develop some genomic tools
for these species where like cure clover
doesn't have markers or a linkage map or
anything yet and so we're developing a
linkage map using capture seek from
Rapid genomics while while also at the
same time you know eventually we'll make
a targeted sequencing panel from the
linkage map choosing markers randomly
distributed across those linkage groups
to make a target panel for the genotype
of the training population initially in
these genomic selection models and so so
that's what I'm doing if you have any
questions I'd like to hear them thank
you
[Applause]
thanks for your presentation
I was wondering out how long you
envision the alfalfa to be president in
an inner crop system like that it seems
like the intermediate wheat grass could
out outlast the Alpha by quite a bit so
just wondering what you had in mind yeah
so so far we've observed animate wheat
grass is that we have declining yields
after you know the second third year I
mean depending where you're at is gonna
determine how long that crops sitting is
gonna be a part of your rotation so it
might not have to be more than four or
five years the one nice thing about the
way we're imagining it is that we allow
time for accumulation of carbohydrates
in the root grounds to increase the
persistence of our alfalfa over time and
so we hope that it's going to stay there
and by you know not actively cutting it
the five times that we would in a normal
year that's gonna help with the system a
little bit and obviously persistence is
part of the selection procedure so
that's why we're really measuring three
years of phenotypic data before we make
selections that were making sure that we
select plants that are really performing
in that way
and and things like cure clover for
example it could be a better candidate
and we haven't really chosen yet cure
clover has this rhizomatous growth it's
it's extremely persistent and it might
stay there longer in the system but
turns and cure clover both have these
really fibrous above-ground root systems
that may end up competing more we don't
really know that my also you know how
allow for this interaction and nitrogen
transfer to occur but we're learning
that through the breeding at the same
time so yep hey when do you expect due
to peak viability for the ability to
cooperate with the other species in your
interpreting yeah so that was one of the
goals for this sort of pre breeding
plant these other varieties in the
system so right now we have about thirty
varieties planted about alpha at least
with intermediate wheat grass around the
country hoping to see you know is there
genetic and phenotypic variation does
the currents or intermediate grass
respond differently and you plan
different varieties between it so that's
like the first experiment right if
nothing if we use the most divergent
phenotypic variation that we have in
varieties in that experiment and there's
no difference maybe we have to go the
opposite direction maybe there's
something we need to be selecting for an
intermediate wheat grass but so far
we've observed quite a bit of variation
and we think greetings gonna work and so
it's at least for adaptation to climate
so in Wisconsin the alfalfa was out
competing in Wisconsin Minnesota both
alpha was out competing the internet
wheatgrass quite a bit in the
establishment year in Kansas it was the
opposite so if we look at like biomass
ratios the alfalfa des enemy at
wheatgrass biomass ratio it's like two
to on and Wisconsin in like one to two
in Kansas so it's the exact opposite and
if we go further and try to figure out
okay what is it about these varieties
that's pausing that fall dormancy seems
to be key so in now alpha we have this
range as a fall dormancy that are we
expect controlled by photo period
sensitivity and so they're gonna start
growing at a certain time of the year
and grasses have some photo Pierson's TV
but they're also more growing degree
dependent and so we accumulate growing
degree days and photo period differently
in both environments so we can imagine
at some point in time you know making
sure we overlap the phenology of those
two things just right so that we can
reduce competition or increase
compatibility however you want to look
at it
so this is really related to what you're
just talking about is that what about
undesirable species since you're not
tilling
what about weeds nutgrass you know all
these other kinds of things that incur
problem fields yeah so so far what we've
seen that's a pretty big problem the
first year of our establishment but most
of the weeds when we think about them in
our cropping systems right now are also
annuals that are adapted to using all
the resources really quickly and growing
really quickly in these early
successional ecosystems and so what
we're finding to some extent is that
when you put a big perennial grass there
and these other perennial the game
species especially the rhizomatous ones
they're gonna they out-compete the weeds
fairly quickly as we move up this
successional gradient in our cropping
system we're gonna have problems with
things like trees and with things like
other you know perennial species that
don't really take hold in our cropping
systems the way we grow them right now
but we haven't had problems with you
know like the Palmer amaranth sand the
things like that after the first year
and so we don't know what's gonna happen
right this is the new frontier so we can
think about continuing to go along
password' to explore things that you
know we've overlooked as humans for the
last 10,000 years we've kind of
overlooked this idea of having perennial
grain crops and it's somewhere that you
know we see how things function in our
earth systems right now that we need to
begin exploring in more detail
so I think the the perennial Lupin idea
is kind of interesting I know that for
annual lupin production there's issues
with anti Nutritionals so in your if
you're looking at lupins is this
something you would want to look at
sooner rather than later because it's
such a big potential roadblock to grain
usage yeah so we are starting
collaborations my little circle diagram
are showing you where we're actually
phenotyping we're doing some aspect work
to look at alkaloid profile so there's
our cloyd's and lupins that are toxic to
mammals and other things one of the
things that's really interesting about
it so we had three species of lupins
that were domesticated in Eden for
thousands of years with the alkaloids
there was always a most of them are
water-soluble and heat sensitive and so
there was a processing step to removing
the alkaloids and they were kind of nice
to have there because they provide sort
of anti herbivore in those cropping
systems and we've now used mutagenesis
three times and removed the alkaloid by
synthesis pathway basically it doesn't
function anymore and the lupins that
we're cultivating now especially in
Australia so all the lupins in Australia
are non bitter types the sweet types
they don't produce alkaloids in Europe
we still have a lot of the bitter types
that are grown and so if you buy like
zucchini beans in Italy or in Palestine
we're just where those are all actually
soaked for multiple days before they're
fed to you so that's a really good
question to think about you know I'm
starting breeding potential new species
is it something I should get rid of or
is this something that I should take
advantage of in designing this crop and
in what sort of food system do you need
to have to control that and so in
Australia they have a law that you can
only have the non bitter types because
they don't want anyone to you know have
have the chance of eating something that
is high in alkaloids in Europe there's
no laws and so everything has to be
processed this kind of the same way I'm
treated like they might have alkaloids
in them
and there's all these fascinating things
like when we talk about high-value
products you know alkaloids are
important in you know for medicinal uses
in etc and so there might be a whole
industries about you know actually
taking the alkaloids out of the lupins
and using them as a secondary product
using the proteins for human consumption
other questions do we have one on Zoom
okay we have a question from Chris
Smallwood Oh uh-huh
what are some challenges he faced with
product development using these
perennial crops and what are some
successes you've had yeah so we've done
no product development so far and and
this is because I'm still trying to
decide what what we're gonna do with it
but we have been doing product
development for other grains at the land
Institute so intermediate wheat grass is
in this pre commercialization stage
under the name the grain sold under the
name Kern's a-- and we just hired a
commercialization manager to oversee
that process and so far there's there's
way more demand and supply available so
we're in this unique state a time where
there's so much demand that we can't
produce enough seed performers to plants
because we're trying to have income to
support the research and etc by selling
the grain to people to eat so hopefully
what we imagine is that people begin
valuing like the plant-based proteins
that we were talking about people begin
valuing things because of the impact
that they have on our environment people
can pay a premium for those things in
the future we we need to do a whole lot
of food safety research before I can
release anything so a current
intermediate wheatgrass has gone through
iterative rounds of applying for these
kind of generally regarded as safe
ingredients so that they can be
registered for use in the US alfalfa is
a really nice candidate also and lupins
because it's already lupins there so
they already have some of those statuses
which which hopefully helps someday in
that process any other questions I have
a question yeah thinking about sort of
how you might transition from annual
systems to these more diverse perennial
systems how do you think it's the best
strategy to go about that what sort of
compromises are you willing to make and
what are you yeah so you know one of the
reasons that I was that we're pushing
towards these dual use you know Forge
grain systems is that we are
compromising right now we're leasing
intermediate we crest as a grain crop
we're not gonna achieve the same yields
as wheat we can you know producing
respectable amounts if there's a premium
value for the for the grain is one way
to move move in that direction and one
of the compromises we're gonna make is
is probably in the amount of
productivity and this is just the way it
is right so anything about wheat it's
got like a 10,000 year head start
we need to envision right 2050 is this
number that we throw out about how are
you gonna feed people in 2050 but we
just need to think about feeding people
in 20 120 150 and what are we going to
do to solve these problems that are
pressing right now we already have upset
biogeochemical systems in the US we need
to start thinking about those problems
as well and so if I don't release
something if there's no printing a
legume crop in the next 10 years I don't
know if that's a problem we really need
them at some point in time someone needs
to start working on them and it
definitely has to not be a me it's got
to be a we like we know that there's no
chance that any of these pretty legume
species can exist or perennial green
crops etc without having a larger you
know scientific public and private
interest and investment in the
development of these crops
[Music]
okay with that let's think Brendan again
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu